good morning John it's Wednesday and you
know what that means I am NOT gonna play
a song yes 2010 is over and that means
that I will never sing another song
again
no more song Wednesdays no more songs
it's over of course I am lying to you I
couldn't stop writing songs if I wanted
to in Lu Lee was a funny word too many
vowels so instead of another song
Wednesday song I covered a song on my
second trainer you can go watch it
there's a notation at the end of the
video ok everybody I want you to listen
to this and picture the man who's saying
it in your head when you're listening to
nothing but the best of oldies you're
listening to magic 98.9 now I want you
to look at this and picture what his
voice would sound like now I want you to
watch this as your mind shall be blown
when you're listening to nothing but the
best of oldies you're listening to magic
989 was your mind blown if it wasn't
it's probably because you already saw
that video and read it or some other way
but let this be a lesson to all of us
the way that we look does not have
anything to do with the way that we
sound or the way that we are we like to
think so in fact we like to think so so
much that we tend to dress up like
people that we are similar to we all
kind of wear uniforms like I go to Old
Navy and I'm like I can't wear that
shirt because I'm not that kind of
person I'm this kind of person what
shirt am i wearing right now I don't
even know I'm the kind of person that
doesn't know I'm wearing my own shirt so
I'm that kind of person but another
great thing about that silky voiced
homeless man is that the video went
viral and he's actually been hired to be
an announcer for a basketball team and
they give it in our house
of course we should all note that silkie
voiced homeless man with the first to
admit that he is not homeless because of
some circumstance outside of his control
he was homeless because of alcohol and
drugs so let this be a lesson to you all
even if you have an amazing skill you
can still screw it up big-time and other
news John your head desk shown here ah
desk was lame let me show you how to
really do a head desk ah yes the trick
to a good head desk of course is the
mousepad additionally a good actual
thump with your fists for thee as they
call it foley effect that's what we're
about here Jon movie magic good special
effects and if you're not behind that
honorable said I don't know if I can
work with you anymore
yeah Destin you couldn't even hear your
head hit the desk pathetic but I need to
have something to head desk about
luckily
I just came across this advertisement
the sensor so pump dispenses soap
touch-free to prevent the spread of
harmful germs ah why do I care if I
touch it if I am invariably going to
wash my hands afterward ah the only use
for this thing is to fill it with vodka
and have it automatically fill your
drinks and as silky voiced homeless man
can attest that is also a bad idea
now finally we move on to the last part
of this video that has had absolutely no
theme at all in which we shall discover
whether or not our strategy has been
successful and see if Google is Auto
completing is Hank green - is Hank green
ah no it is not wait what's this Bing
what's bit oh my god Bing got it on is H
okay I mean I'm not gonna say anything
about about Google because they run this
video sharing site here that I sort of
love but y'all seriously get get on top
of this now let's see if they got
anything for a hankering at you oh hey
green is cute yes and now of course we
must check jump oh oh well for this
purpose at least I have to say from my
perspective
Bing is better than Google I don't know
what else to talk about they all look
it's a video of a lilac opening I did
this with my garden watch cam thing that
my parents got me isn't it awesome they
got it from ThinkGeek
which is the only place I ever want
people to buy me presents from again and
I always say that because I buy
everything that dftba records produces
so if you buy me a present from dftba
records um i already have it
speaking of dftba records we just
launched a new version of our website
it's gorgeous
what should I do now yes I've decided to
go running Oh dog is angry at me just
running down the alley so you can see
our beautiful winter wonderland John
I'll see you on Friday